I know for London Fink news a world
champion in fake news the Israeli Prime
Minister takes to Facebook to discredit
an Israeli journalist and the channel he
works for for broadcasting leaks to do
with the corruption cases against the
Prime Minister Israeli media now
reporting that the journalist has hired
a bodyguard because of the anonymous
threats he's received Netanyahu I think
that media is very important he gives a
lot of importance to the media and he
wants to shape the public opinion he
wants to influence and he's obsessed and
he's panicked he's terrified you can
never see that because it's a good actor
he never shows his fear but this week
all we saw some signs of it because
there was a recording that was leaked
that he was screaming in a secret
recording Netanyahu can be heard
screaming at his then Communications
Minister telling him to intervene in
order to allow a sympathetic channel to
broadcast news something it had not been
allowed to do before Netanyahu had been
banned by the Attorney General from
interfering in the affairs of the media
and this an official campaign video from
Likud the Prime Minister's party once
again singling out journalists who
reported on leaks related to the
corruption cases this video tells the
audience they will not decide this is
the second election in six months and
the big question is can Benjamin
Netanyahu win again and if he does can
you form a government but it's really
the day and often that's going to
determine what happens to Israel's
longest serving Prime Minister just a
couple of weeks after the vote he faces
a hearing on corruption charges and the
worst case scenario for Benjamin
Netanyahu is jail Netanyahu is facing
three criminal cases of corruption and
fraud two of them are linked allegations
of giving the Prime Minister favorable
coverage in the media for Netanyahu the
media is both the strength of his
success the secret to his success and
the possible way that it's going to get
a failure I like to say that for
Netanyahu the media is like kryptonite
to Superman because it can disable him
and he's afraid of it and almost every
problem that he's had
legal problem and bribery scale had to
do with protecting his image in the
media voters go to the polls on the 17th
of September but in the end the fate of
Israel's Prime Minister lies in the
hands of this country's legal system
Stephanie Decker al Jazeera West
Jerusalem